we finally got the moment we have been
waiting for all season the judges gave
out their very first ten
my reaction to having the first perfect
score of the season oh man honestly
cloud9 I just feel like it's a
mountaintop moment
we saw tens across the board for you
this is a perfect night that my parents
they're to have a kids there but the big
shocker came when Ally ended up in the
bottom two
despite her perfect score like what is
happening maybe people think oh she's
got three tens she's good we don't need
to vote you know along with Ally on the
chopping block the office star and fan
favorite Kate Flannery she was
ultimately sent home by the judges a
decision they did not want to make it's
disappointing to see people go home like
this week after week and Shawn is
staying in yeah I'm a little frustrated
I'm a lot frustrated you know what we
came we did our best
this is this show it's slightly baffling
from time to time and I think we're just
you know people vote that's all you know
all we can do is dance still we had a
little consolation prize for Kate a
message from her former office co-star
John Krasinski Kate you are rushing keep
going because I think you're going all
the way
[Music]